[Música]
este vídeo publicado por la agencia
espacial rusa roscósmos muestra el
segmento ruso de la estación espacial
internacional desprendiéndose dejándolo
a merced de la atracción gravitatoria de
la tierra el jefe de roscósmos dice que
occidente se arriesga a que esto ocurra
y afirma que la órbita de la estación no
lo llevaría a caer sobre rusia sino en
otro lugar sobre quién podría caer la
estación espacial internacional de 500
toneladas la población de otros países
incluidos los dirigidos por perros de la
guerra
deberían pensar en el precio de las
sanciones que iniciaron contra roscósmos
se trata de una amenaza vacía o una
preocupación seria rusia es responsable
de mantener la estación a flote y es
cierto que si cayera a la tierra no toda
ella se quemaría en la atmósfera pero
rusia también es responsable de apartar
la estación espacial internacional de
los desechos espaciales si deja de
cooperar podría estar poniendo en
peligro la vida de tres de sus
cosmonautas que están a bordo
en cualquier caso empresas como northrop
grumman y space six están interviniendo
para asegurarse de que la estación en
órbita y sea maniobrable pero para la
nasa el riesgo no es solo una caída
repentina a la tierra sino una triste
pérdida de colaboración científica
internacional
sería muy difícil para nosotros operar
por nuestra cuenta la estación es una
asociación internacional que se creó con
dependencias conjuntas que es lo que
hace que sea un programa tan increíble
jon amazing y el desmantelamiento
controlado de la estación espacial
internacional está previsto para 2031
cuando se dirigirá hacia una tumba
acuática en el océano pacífico